what is going on there reject nation
greg and john here today we are going to
watch the next
episode for superman and lois i want to
say a big thank you to everyone who has
shown their support over at our patreon
page cooling to watch along is where you
sync up with the time code for superman
and lois are
over there as well as a bunch of other
shows editing these reactions it's
difficult to
get them monetize or maintain them being
monetized
so speaking of which thank you to
today's video sponsor ridge
wallet guys you know i've said it since
episode one
you know what would make jordan and
jonathan great parents
are the kids david they would be amazing
kids to their father clark kent
if they got him a ridge wallet for
father's day
that's right man think of all the
benefits superman could glean from a
super
durable strong ridge wallet it's got
rfid
blocking so no one can use their x-ray
vision to steal his bank information it
comes in aluminum
carbon fiber titanium some of the
strongest metals
they got tens of thousands of five-star
reviews too and you know how much
clark loves a good report you know he
loves
journalism we are successfully tying all
this
into superman and lois to justify it
being here
and plus you know superman can fly
around the world he would make a great
delivery man but you know what ridge is
doing one better because when you go to
ridge.com
reject nation use our special code
reject nation you get 10
off in free shipping worldwide so not as
fast as superman
and it costs just as much
but it's free the next word while the
shout out i'm going to tell a story of
when i was at a strip club once
with your father for father
[Music]
why is edge here
smallville's the only town where he's
sticking around
he needs this place how do you suggest
we figure out why
how do you suggest you do journalism
how does one investigate a story clark's
a great reporter
he's gonna he's gonna do reporting he's
gonna do clark things
i know your life hasn't been easy
knowing you can't provide for your
family that
i can improve you emily
step inside my iron lung do you want to
become
your best self do you want to live your
best life
sell me this pen
all right guys we're probably gonna have
another late night working on this edge
case
we were gonna see sarah's review tonight
anyway so
to support her dad she's trying to
support her dad
i'm not a left-hand shop jordan
listen i um i just want to say thank you
for
stepping up and helping sarah with our
audition the other day that uh
that really saved the day man keep it up
you'll be the next morgan edge
hey we'll see you later okay yeah
love you i'm a supporter dad
i'm supportive dad i made up for missing
your thing right
things improve for a little bit it's the
same crap as always and then he crashes
like your brother's about to yeah i told
you stay away from tegan wickham
just trust me okay why why can't he have
anything
why can't he have tegan wickham
the watchdogs
i don't know the point of this fight but
hell yeah
hell yeah
cool
cool
oh no it's infiltrated his lungs
like that terminator i know
oh soups
okay i get the point of the fight
[Laughter]
he has to be superman and save lives
and he's gonna do it for the entire
world
what the hell is going on
el superman i return to you now
carl the white
glasses before if they went right into
that bvs shot
crap rather mr looks up almost
[Laughter]
i just sent someone over with a massive
add buy for tomorrow's paper
for more recruits twice as many where
are you going
oh to make a scene
i love the string music and the pulse
yeah it's like a paul thomas anderson
movie
there will be ex kryptonite you don't
want anything to do with what he's
offering
miss lane you all need to walk away
right now walk away
where's kyle when you need him these
people
are not puppets to be controlled by you
they have
dreams they have families no one's being
forced to do anything against their will
everyone's made the same off perhaps
it's time you use that device you have
to call in your
super friend he may take comfort knowing
there are others here just like him
no he won't ah we've already had that
talk
why doesn't he just take the kryptonian
oh it's because he'll be the
consciousness
yeah he wants to still be morgan edge
yeah it's like you finally figured out
that locker
yeah no uh yeah i took your advice you
know nothing good ever comes from anger
so
he spent many nights practicing that
rehearsing this
i i was just wondering if like maybe uh
you wanted to
like hang out after school sometime hang
out
just the two of us yeah i mean
you say hang out i just thought like we
were
training looks and well yeah i mean
you had that broken arm and you looked
so lonely i was just
trying to be nice oh look
jonathan no no no no it's uh
the coaches watching jesus drop and give
me 20 kent
looks like you need a new playbook qb
number two you got to work on closing
that deal like you close your locker
dude the show's so mean it hates
jonathan
[Laughter]
superhero body shot god what happened
oh i just stopped this bank robbery and
i got hit did they use cryptonite
no regular bullets this isn't normal
superman doesn't bruise especially not
from bullets
but do you want to go to the bedroom
really quick i mean this is pretty hot
right
i don't know i'm gonna have to call my
dad
oh great can i have to call him and
[ __ ] him out
how are you so awesome at piano do you
have any other little
secret talents you're not telling me
about um [ __ ]
thank you for everything it really means
a lot
having you here so i want to be here oh
no
oh no i i um
i must have allergies or something oh no
jordan sure you're frozen snot she'll
understand
you're sick oh no
oh damn oh oh oh no
[Laughter]
i love the tote of this episode i know
you're affected too
what's happening for kryptonite gas that
rosetta used on me at the dod it was a
bio weapon and i think it might be
communicable oh
damn jesus sickness
from you yeah well
i'm not that bad
oh no this wasn't supposed to happen
okay
it doesn't matter now my guys are
working on it
that's what shirts
love it i've been meaning to ask you
how's it going with the program
you know that he somehow figured out a
process to completely transform people's
lives
it's what process i'm sorry i
assumed you'd already gone through it no
i haven't
awkward mr ash was very clear we don't
tell anyone
emily we've known each other since the
fifth grade i
i got you this job you think i i am
responsible for your life change
oh it seems
you've been looking into things that
don't concern you hmm
emily told me about a process she went
under
what is she talking about an offer i
made her
the same one i'm about to make right now
oh okay to you
and make no mistake the answer you give
will impact the rest of your life
so she says no she's in trouble yep
she's gonna get written up
your grandfather's working with the
doctors to figure out a way to help him
jonathan he's gonna be fine
damn that does not seem
fine oh god
we can't wait for your dad
wow what a shot yeah they go to fort
fortress
yeah they have to be all my life your
job
was your number one priority knowingly
and willingly endangering the lives of
the people i love
i can't forgive that
so when this is over i want you to leave
and never come back
oh you're not welcome here anymore hmm
unless superman needs to work with him
on something yeah it's gonna make some
awkward family confrontations
hey can i borrow him for a terrorist
situation
some off cgi there but all right
oh hey green screen the kryptonite is
causing his lungs to fill with fluid
can you get the kryptonite out of them
but only the same way we have with you
in the past what oh we're gonna have to
burn the kryptonite out of your system
oh my god he's going to be painful
some immense heat no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no listen to me listen to me
this is the only way okay i'll be right
here you're gonna take my hand
okay you're gonna squeeze oh
you can do this this chair just breaks
my heart i know
[Music]
i feel like i can't turn around without
one of you being immortal danger wise
it's so hard to keep you safe
it's part of being a super family i
guess
being the extraordinary humans that'll
figure something out
jonathan you are the only thing keeping
this family together
that's your superpower buddy
you're the most important one of all
good
hey hey who's there's good dad
i love my daughter hey hey included my
act
would you like some water
[Laughter]
how did everything go with that he
explained everything to me it all makes
perfect sense
yeah thank you
oh no no jordan
i'm sorry i can't do this yes you can
yeah okay kyle
kyle kyle
all the men in her life are stepping up
[Laughter]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
this is good yeah she's doing a good job
she has talent
damn this good dad [ __ ] is breaking my i
don't
this is the first time i've been like
super rooting for kyle
and now jordan can take credit for
fixing their relationship
thank you dad for helping me
let's go out for some drinks let's go to
chili's no this is what i feared
oh oh god kryptonian does not want to be
at the talent show
oh where are you going avery's not done
yet i'll be right back
now that's an unsupported parent yummy
you see what's wrong wait kyle
i'm the expert on this
[Laughter]
have you seen this he's still weak the
exact reason why i just activated some
of our subjects
to take down superman not him the one he
protects
oh gosh
leave him alone that's it
it's over that's it it's over you're
done just give me an answer
[Music]
oh god oh no oh you better save the day
grandpa
yeah make yourself useful for once
hey lana lois you know how you kept
asking me if anyone over at edge
intercourse was acting differently
i just saw it for the first time with
emily fan she left in the middle of her
daughter's performance she would never
do that
she was someone else
oh don't don't don't you touch him hey
mom i think
it's for you lois was worried
no no no he's doing it
she shouldn't have called
[Music]
not this time
oh god
oh good job graham scrims
keep hitting this till he comes it's all
we can do no no no we need to go to the
bar
i [ __ ] love this show so much
i just came from the performance lana
was i don't like the frame rate on you
i don't either shutter speed yeah
stay down stay down
oh
what a beautiful ass shot damn
holy crap it's like prometheus yeah
your life right now has completely
changed because of who i am you didn't
ask for any of this
but you didn't ask for what happened to
you either
[Music]
let's go get a ridge wallet
as long as they don't make them in
kryptonite
[Music]
double duty here give me the gun no
that frame rate
oh wow no kyle took it didn't he
pretty good with that thing
no told you it was gonna happen knew it
i knew it
oh who's gonna kill you lois
he wanted you to suffer first oh
damn
they're gone damn it kyle seriously
that's why he was so chipper
that's why he's such a good guy
the steps you're taking to improve
yourself
god
it was him wasn't it it was him i should
have said it i
knew it i was
[Music]
how can i help you i knew it i want to
be my best self
i i wanted to be better for for you and
for our girls and for morgan edge
burma sayers and david fugelstad
who leslie lar and motel attacker guy
leslie lars real name is irma sayers
and guess what i found out they're both
originally from
smallville it's not smallville edge
needs to build his army it's the people
oh so it's just everyone's a carrier
that's good that's clever
superhero landing i'm glad you came
no way oh no way
oh you can't make that happen any more
than she can
oh no no
no oh
oh [ __ ] did you really think i'd be
giving people powers without having them
myself
i got mine the same time you did when i
arrived on this planet
when you arrived oh no
no no no no no the truth about who i am
and where i'm really from oh jesus
brother ah dude
what a beautiful ending shot too
oh i'm from krypton with a c
sister plan
we invented cryptocurrency
the kryptonite of all common modern
minds
damn wow i said it too i was like why
didn't he just give himself power yeah
damn he didn't give himself powers he
has power he's just
he's better than all of us maybe he's
born with it maybe it's maybelline
he's born with this try to get a
sponsorship for that we should get a
maybelline
sponsorship ladies come on
it's tough being a father john yeah
that's what this episode taught me today
i'm tough being a dad man it's tough
being there
it's tough making the hard choices and
protecting your loved ones
look i know there's a lot to talk about
in this episode there's a lot that
happened
but we gotta shout out jonathan can for
being oh
freaking mvp he gets turned down
humiliated by his coach
moments after getting turned down and
he's still like
mom look it's not your fault look i'm
here for you jordan you all right yeah i
just saved the day blasted these fools
but jordan y'all
i'm glad you made it through the
kryptonite he is like the most selfless
kid
never been anywhere near as close as
being a good of a person as that guy
is this it's literally goals because
especially after
what was that the last episode where he
kind of gets pushed to a breaking point
and he like lashes out and then you know
especially since then it's like
damn you're on like another level of
understanding and you even stood up to
grandpa
you know being like yeah we might both
be the normies in this family but i'm
not
like you i'm a better i have more
character than you
yeah it's great it's awesome what they
do with that character man i really love
him a lot he's my
he's my favorite for for all the reasons
that we just said
i just want to hang out with him yeah
that girl doesn't know what she's
missing yeah
dumb ass seriously this guy
you can treat this guy like crap but
he'll still be like all right honey i
understand here's some flowers
i'm the best guy
you walk all over that guy yeah and it
was my fault for looking so sad and
having a cast
but yeah i think he is um i think he is
you know i'm just keeping the headphones
on screw it it's the look for today yeah
uh yeah i think i think that was cool i
love
how him and lois working together at the
end it was neat to have
yeah like superman does show up at the
to take out kyle but
the real mvps of the fight were people
who were not super powered
especially like i love seeing lotus and
jonathan the non-superpowered people of
the family
working together taking on the baddies
and stuff being smart
it was good there's good stuff and then
i really i really love how this carried
over from the last episode because this
is
serial storytelling they're doing you
know like they're not none of this is
felt episodic at all
like i made my crack i already got crap
in the comments there's a lot of people
who will like
leave their rough comment down below
they will not make it to this part of
the video but when we made the joke
about like i don't know what the point
of this fight is when he goes to mexico
or something
i know the point if it's just but
superman's life i get it all
day job right know it'll happen every
day it's so often does the fight itself
and this robbery pertain to the bigger
plot at hand no that was what the joke
was about but i know that
this is what he has to do every single
day all right yeah and
it makes all of the other struggles that
much more legitimate just because he has
this to juggle too
exactly like just going about his normal
day routine and then you see that the
virus that's affecting him
uh hinders him on the job that he has to
do every day to keep the world safe
so yeah and but trust me
trust me you're going to see people be
like this is what he does
show that he was infected from the
kryptonite
i'm not going to watch far enough into
the fight for you to get to the moment
where that's very clear
yeah and i i i do appreciate like it's
such a big reveal in the last one of
like oh man and you know it's not
a stretch to imagine that like i get
what sam is saying like it's my job to
think of the worst case scenarios and
plan for that
but i love that they took it one step
further with the whole virus
aspect and the fact that he can like
communicate it to jordan and everything
like he's
you said that in the episode i think you
literally said like this was the last
thing i expected and
yeah it turns it into something more
interesting and more complex
and weirdly it almost seems a little
more relevant just because of you know
communicable disease situations
happening in the world
you know even superman has that to deal
with yeah
it's a pandemic for two yep yep
pandemic for well and you know hey uh
maybe some of those other kryptonians
because he put more gas in there that's
how they'll take them down yeah
give everyone liars give everyone just a
bad respiratory kryptonite infection
uh yeah that's a very good point i i
love
the bonding that they do with all the
characters here superman
and um jordan like i was so endeared to
their
this this episode just had so much heart
mixed with
amazing cinematography and an a solid
grip on the rhythm
for its editing like the right music
choices i reference paul thomas anderson
because it does kind of have a little
bit
of that like consistent percolating
tension but that energy and the certain
types of wide framing and the cutting it
was a lot of it
that was making me just directly think
of
of movies that from uh more like
not so much there will be kind of like
there will be blood but more like
magnolia
or something like that that kind of
shoot filming that he would do
that have energy but still this sort of
uh uh deliberate fluidity
yeah you know yeah and uh you you get
all these great qualities here and i
think what they did with kyle
as well is was so smart because it seems
like he's just so
chipper they got me they got me yeah
like at the beginning of the episode i
was like maybe that's
kyle i think it's i think it's probably
kyle and but
just kept my mouth shut just waiting
this is the first this is the most i
regret
not making it right we're both on the
same page and it's kyle because we
it seemed like the show was headed that
way where he would sign up for whatever
this is
and the way it's shot so idyllic you're
just like this has to be kyle vision
yeah and then they mislead you with the
shot with lana
where it's the same shot but a different
line that morgan edge starts the
conversation off with but i forgot that
it was a different line until they went
back to it i'm like oh that was the clue
right there
yeah it was the line is different so
very well done um but
yeah with kyle you think it's all to do
with i don't know maybe you guys
figured out before way before we did but
what the show was at least attempted to
do it worked on us
was kyle really messed up last time so
he's just trying to be a good dad so the
show does a really good job with
starting off with kyle dropping sarah
off at school
and being like hey i'm an overly
optimistic dad
see look how i've changed i'm not gonna
be a neglectful abusive father anymore
i'm a good guy i'm involved
hey you're her friends come on over here
i love you guys too have fun at school
everyone and it seemed like that's what
it was uh uh all that was what the whole
personality was about like he shows up
at the show he has a guitar
it's like super it's kind of cheesy i
love this you know so time brought me to
tears
i was so touched by it at the same time
it was just so
like funny yeah he's just back there
guitar don't need to tune it let's go
well that's the thing is that's a way in
which i think the episode does and
successfully so managed to have its cake
and eat it too where it's like you know
the second jordan's not gonna be able to
make the talent show you know oh this is
kyle's big opportunity to step in and
make the save
and so then yeah when the twist with him
finally comes around
you know you get that yeah it is a
little bit cheesy because you know it's
coming but at the same time it's
touching and then there's this other
horror shoe waiting to drop on you and
so yeah like having
such an emotional swell on kyle's behalf
then yeah makes the i thought they it
added to the moment at the end because
then i was saying they're going he's
either going to die and i'm going to be
bummed
and unexpectedly or you know he's going
to have
gone through the process yeah because
there's so many little details that were
hinting to it
like for example he's the one who went
out to talk to was it emily is the girl
oh um i can't remember her last name fan
the the woman yeah yes somebody fan
emily fan the woman who i think is a
filipino sister am i
hey but i'm probably wrong but she looks
filipino to me
i'll call her the filipino woman for the
rest of this review isn't it racist if
you try to guess someone and this is
like genet like you know ethnic
background and
you know you make a decent guess but
it's wrong
but but i'm the race so i'm applying my
filipino race
towards her so i can call her the
filipino woman
to come to find out later she's really
vietnamese
yeah or indonesian or something yeah
we're just straight-up totally messed up
yes so uh yeah she's uh
yeah when kyle goes to check up on her
in the bathroom
to me and like my mom went oh okay well
yeah they live in the same town the
family friends i i guess
it makes sense that he would do it it
just seemed odd to me how he was
taking the initiative so much on it yeah
and
because it seemed like lana would be the
one to go to talk to her it makes more
sense
and then to find out oh it's kyle's in
the same program as her
so you know like maybe he was checking
up on
like he felt more comfortable to be the
one who initiated i don't to me that's
like a little indicator of
a little more of the clues that they had
that kyle was really uh
yeah i was really possessed by the
kryptonian power
yeah this is my favorite morgan edge
episode too absolutely so far
the best one uh i loved seeing
this because that's what his personality
is it's a riff on like your corporate
greedy dude who
pretends to look out for the little
people and manipulates his words and
really he's just trying to profit off of
you
it's funny because we just finished
supernatural season seven which had a
very similar kind of
so many roman vibes like terrible yeah
doing terrible things to the to the
little towns people or to the
to people yeah in the world the
population of earth
who he lives completely down upon yeah
yeah and then uh morgan edgar
i love uh the way he was here this felt
the most
less mustache twirly of all the ones
that he's done so far
he really thought that hit what his
character was just clicked better for me
here
he feels more realized by this point
because now you can watch him operate as
his plan is in motion and we know
pat like i appreciated that where it's
like you know when he is talking to lois
it's basically clear that yes we're on
the same page about what i'm doing you
just can't prove it
and so to see him you know not at least
for us as the audience having to uphold
that you know mystery of like oh you
know what's going on with him you know
it feels like and especially by the end
of this one
like they don't it seems like they don't
uh uh
keep anything drawing out longer than it
needs to be
and so it feels like the appropriate
point to get him on to the next level of
like what's your master plan you know
so yeah it was like an investigative
mystery uh
had that pulse to it and yet
they don't really walk out the winners
in the end because
they've done a good job with painting
the gray and the only one who's really
in a black and white situation but i'm
kind of wondering if we're gonna start
getting to a gray area
now that we're learning that morgan edge
is he calls him brother so he must be
kryptonian right it looks like he's got
the same powers he's wearing like some
like sideways symbol of hope something
that looks like a chaotic version of the
superman symbol yeah gothic metal
version or something i don't know this
is the
messed up verse it's from the comic i
don't remember all right
look does you clown on us all you want i
don't remember but
um yeah maybe we'll get more of the
greater there because so far he's been
the one who
who you've you've never you could always
feel there's something
uh selfishly maliciously intent about
what he's doing even though he's
putting under the veil of of
looking out for the people where
everyone else you get kind of this gray
area like even with
um the dad uh the grandpa what's his
name sam
sam sam lee sam sarah okay sam
with sam uh how you know he's making his
arguments and i
don't you're i'm totally on like lois's
side but i completely let me touch on
this last time i get where he's coming
from you know
like he's not the whole family the only
one he's not blood with
is superman you know so he can't fully
trust him even though he's
quote unquote family and he wasn't
introduced to
who superman is as hey this is clark
he's
superman he's like what's superman never
heard of superman
he was fully aware of superman before he
ever learned who superman really was and
superman was marrying his daughter right
so it makes
sense that he has this instilled in him
and the arguments he presents i can't
really argue um against
why he's doing what he's doing and i
like that the show even goes out of its
way to sort of
support some of that to a certain extent
because
if he didn't have those kryptonian
weapons they would have
died yeah absolutely it came in clutch
and and
you know again again superman and jordan
wouldn't be off at the fortress of
solitude and superman could have showed
up
see it's good yeah because boom
arguments there's a good everywhere
cause and effect there yeah but it does
at least
at least now that the pandora's box has
been opened it yeah is lucky that he's
at least
like helping with the leg up on the
preparedness to take care of this that
was so eloquent but but yeah
like i love that they you know they say
that like the key to good drama is
having every character sort of believe
they're doing the right thing and have a
compelling argument and i feel like that
scene between him and jonathan
is is it's you know it's not a scene i
left or i think you're supposed to leave
going like oh yeah
jonathan definitely [ __ ] slapped him in
that argument it's like no jonathan's
got a solid point
i get where sam's coming from too and i
just see what's they're good at showing
you just what's
hard about that situation and i love the
way that they kind of apply that
humanity across everything because yeah
it's like sam
he's drawn as this you know oh he's
suspicious of clark
and you know the superman and everything
but you still
get the human struggle and the urge to
do the right thing and i loved
the you know later scene in the episode
with him and lois where he finally you
know
uh owns up into some of their
relationship in the past as well as
you know where they're at now and i
wonder what him rededicating his
attention and resources to smallville is
gonna look like and if that's gonna help
her if that's gonna hurt or what
he's gonna die by the end of season one
i would not be surprised
it really seems like they're signed up
for that i mean i predicted a kyle death
yeah i'm predicting a general sam death
i could see yeah it'd be so obvious kyle
was going to join the
power power patrol
yeah yeah he was going to go undergo the
process
it's interesting they make you care
about a lot i haven't cared about the
my filipino friend yeah dude you should
call her and see if she's okay
yeah panoy pride lady yeah but in
japanese leave me alone
none of your guesses have been correct
you lay ocean right
but uh i don't know they do like a
really wonderful job of having all this
sci-fi and all this like you know big
like they put in the action and
everything but even when it's just like
superman and jordan in the fortress of
solitude or even before that like
those emotional moments of parenting
somehow wind up feeling just as intense
and just as lucid
as you know the big cool stuff you know
well this show seems to be so much about
father and sons
or just being parent yeah that's what
the the main
theme of this seems to be it's like i
love how these episodes so much of them
end with just
well that was the adventure of the day
jordan what happened like then
like jordan jonathan talking with each
other yeah yeah yeah
like uh hanging out having this chat and
sam
you know still at the talent show two
episodes in a row
oh yes welcome to the talent show for
sarah
sarah sarah dammit dammit i would love
to see sam at the time
i made these guns i guess you could call
that a talent
but yeah is she gonna take jordan back
is she gonna be crushed is the love
gonna die
because i think jordan should just tell
her i wondered if
that's where that was leading with the
whole like can we talk thing like
i i'm sure that everyone you know if
he's to have a
you know conference with everyone in his
family would be like don't tell her at
all but
i wonder if they'll go there i almost
feel like they might
i mean might put things at a bit of a
odd conflict though she does learn that
her daddy
has the kryptonian in him oh yeah and um
see this show is good enough escalating
yeah this show is good enough to the
point where i
i come to now expect that they're gonna
choose the path of the most interesting
conflicts instead of you know like
trying to
be too fussy about maintaining a certain
enjoyable status quo or whatever
well the reveal that they did about why
they're in smallville
so smart that was smart yeah
it's so much more purposeful versus
just another story of taking advantage
of the small town people yeah
it's it almost harkens to like those
stories like like an erin brockovich
type thing where it's like it was in the
water all along and it had these
physical effects on people
except you know there's a sci-fi slant
on it you know which just it goes to
bolster
you know the corporate morgan edge sort
of allegory story
well it makes sense i mean superman
landed there and so more people there
would be
exposed to the kryptonite and used to it
so the body like that is
that's that's so smart to for a very
intentional reason to put morgan edge in
smallville
yeah right when they move back
it's clever to me like that's yeah
that's a good way to keep your big
corporate baddie who's also now a super
villain yeah we had to give it a sense
of purpose instead of just like it just
happened to be smallville
the wrong place but it raises so many
questions what's morgan edge been doing
how long has he just been on this planet
in disguise
where was he during infinity war in a
game why didn't he intervene
i mean that's the problem with anybody
overpowered is like that
yeah you have to wonder like what are
you doing the rest of the time
yeah you never fought with superman you
just kept these powers hidden for so
many years like that you've been here
you know i need to build up my corporate
side so that it'll be really convincing
when i do unveil myself
or like how long has he had his powers
you know yeah
it's uh he's sitting at the same time i
got my powers the same time
you did so i mean it seems like he's
just full kryptonian you know
yeah is it just are they gonna do a zod
thing i wonder
i'm gonna do that zod thing i mean it
does to me suggest
that it i don't expect not clark or
superman
i don't want it to be sad either i mean
it suggests to me that they're gonna at
least feel that fire of like oh well
he's got you know other kryptonian as
much as i don't think
that is actually going to get to this
universe's superman
i could see the brother angle he decked
him so it's starting off very
adversarial but i could imagine a world
in which they used that to mind some
sort of character conflict
for clark in some way and maybe that
could be more interesting
well they're evil ass kryptonians no
kryptonians
a lot of times just seem like dicks it
seems like we got lucky
with the the one the one gryptonians
well there's a super girl out there too
that's true that's fair right now
and now there's gonna be 20 others with
evil conscious the evil kryptonians
but don't worry tag will join the team
because he's just naturally
kryptonized a bunch of dumbasses you
could prepare to leave the planet
yeah you could you should just listen to
jorel you would have left the planet
you'll be fine
yeah but your stubborn asses got you
killed
dumbass yeah yeah jeez
kick them all while they're down to all
those who are super sensitive to their
kryptonian fan base so all those
kryptonian relatives
not trying to offend you
[Music]
oh yeah it doesn't seem like much good
comes from krypton
no except for a couple of things anyway
yeah did we cover everything we needed
to cover yeah we we got jordan and
jonathan and sarah's
show and and kyle and morgan yeah
sarah's a good sam
max just trying to get an album done so
she asked if she could promote it here
on superman
lois right dude they're doing it well
you know that's part of being on cw
they're like we gotta squeeze a musical
episode in here somewhere anybody
trying to get a pop career going well i
feel like this is
sam sarah is uh being pushed back a
little bit
like uh she seemed like she was kind of
an interesting compelling
smart uh not smart ass but like
sarcastic
she got spunk but wisecracking you know
um teen character from before with like
a depression background
and and lately she's just kind of been
like indeed
she's become like the lana lang or just
that girl who's in danger
being courted being let down by someone
who's courting them
yeah yeah you know i'm like we need i
don't know what you really do with her
to make her to to put her on the same
playing field as the other
members of the cast that's why i'm like
just loop her in it'll make her more
interesting if she knows what's going on
i think that yeah yeah i'm hoping and i
kind of
right now i'm sort of expecting that
that might happen because i think you're
absolutely right
and it's like they i've been invested in
her stories up until this point but it
does seem like there needs to be
something else
for her to do other than you know these
these couple of high school-y things
and to be sort of a motivator for action
of like the male characters in her life
like
you know this her presence goes to do
things for kyle's story and for jordan's
story
in a lot of ways in this episode
sometimes jonathan's
and sometimes jonathan she warned him
about about that one chick
but she does yeah i know she was a total
[ __ ] she was a
[ __ ] about it so taken
pity on jonathan looking at him
down yeah just like feeling bad about it
i saw you looking like a [ __ ] with your
cast on
i was being it took pity on you and
i'm sorry oh so
evil because to me it almost was like
okay what are they trying to do here
they just try to show an example of like
a girl being nice a guy getting that
misconstrued
taking a swing and then just being kind
of cool when she rejects him
like that she handled that well which is
like yeah it's like it's good to see
a great way to handle
yeah i thought it was leading to that
moment and she was cool about it
yeah maybe that's why sarah was like
don't don't don't miss you know she's
too cool
she's too cool you're not going to get
much uh mindable conflict for the
episode out of this i wouldn't
pursue this plotline all right guys well
leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button last but not least
let's do a p
david gandy david my friend
you are amazing ladies and gentlemen
here's a photo for you
boom that's me with an oculus 2
quest two john got one too but i'm not
in this photo
it's officially only featuring myself
here even though john also
got one and who did we get this from
david gaines
that's right david if anyone here
is like a a great father who wants to
show us
other worldly experiences
it is you you are the
superman of our patreon page
and we are both your jordan we are both
your neighbors
none of us is good enough to be jonathan
thank you so much for everything
you have ever ever said or done
for us you have been incredibly helpful
constantly looking out for us making
sure we have time to relax and you just
bought yourself
a house in arizona meaning
between this the oculus quest 2 being
one of our top pledges over at patreon
for so long
how much money do you have david can we
see a full report of your tax returns
i need to know if there's something
illegal going on here
because it just seems like you're
spending way too much money
don't monitor money through the patreon
okay as someone who loves
wonder why that's thank you
jokes for you david that pulled me out
of my bed that was good
no problem that's the first time all
right
anyway back in character
thanks david thanks david i love you
[Music]
buddy